The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Great.
OK.
So today's lecture is on
transit service reliability.
This is my penultimate
lecture, because we
have guest lecturers, too.
So let's start out with what
is reliable transit for you.
What do you think of when you
think of reliable transit?
What does it mean for you?
And I'll write a few
videos on the board.
[CHALK ON BLACKBOARD]
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Arrival at or
close to scheduled arrival.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
Low variance, OK, of--
there's a word for that.
Punctuality, right?
So let's use that.
Just because it's hard to
write on the board with chalk.
It's hard to spell
correctly, actually, when
you're close up to the board.
Emily.
AUDIENCE: Lack of disruption.
So it's the same
service every weekday.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: And
you kind of got two of them.
Lack of disruptions
is one of them
and you said the
same service, right?
So I guess predictability.
Great.
AUDIENCE: The word
legibility, which
is that you sort of know
where transit is going
and it makes sense.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You called it legibility?
AUDIENCE: Legibility.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
That's coining a new term there.
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
It's coining a new term.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You had one.
AUDIENCE: Oh, not in the US.
[LAUGHTER]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
[INAUDIBLE]..
I appreciate the humor, though.
Any other ideas?
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
quality of the ride
is always the same,
like tables are clean.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Consistent quality.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's always possible
to enter the car.
Surrounding is consistent.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Sufficient capacity.
Actually.
AUDIENCE: I think it also
has to cover all the places
you want to go in like a 90--
some kind of percentile of
what you want to travel,
so you're not getting a car
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yep.
And so that includes [INAUDIBLE]
coverage, which is spatial,
and also span of service,
right, which is the same thing
but temporal.
[WRITING ON BOARD]
OK, these are some good ideas.
AUDIENCE: I have a real--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: I said I
have a real one now.
Consistent fare structure or--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
That's usually consistent.
Are you thinking of
a particular example?
AUDIENCE: I think of
just when places where
the price keeps rising often.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
I'll say-- I don't know.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] transfers
[INAUDIBLE] confusing.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Good communication
of fare policy, so
a clear fare policy.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
[WRITING ON BOARD]
Eli.
AUDIENCE: I feel like
we haven't worked
in maintenance of headways and
high-frequency service in here.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's kind of
covered by punctuality
and predictability--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
But it's a little different.
And we're going to talk
a lot about that today.
So let's add that in.
So even headways?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You wouldn't say short headways.
That's not necessarily
part of the liability.
AUDIENCE: Well, it seems
like we're sort of actually
expanding the traditional
definition for liability here.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Yeah, we have been.
I'm not filtering too
much out because--
I guess we'll stop here.
The point I wanted
to make is that--
I'll come back to
this in lecture--
reliability means a lot of
things to different people.
And doing all these
things can be difficult.
So we're going to talk
about some aspects.
We're going to focus
more on punctuality, lack
of disruptions, predictability.
We'll talk about common
equality in system.
That has to do
with even headways.
We're not going to talk so much
about fair policy, or coverage,
or span of service,
or legibility.
All right.
So right.
So impacts of
unreliability, the causes
of unreliability, how
to measure unreliability
or reliability, and then
real-time control strategies.
We've mentioned some
of these topics before.
Now let's focus on these things.
OK, so passenger impacts.
What happens when
service is unreliable?
We have longer
waiting times, right?
We have the need to have a
longer reliability buffer.
So have we talked about
reliability buffer
before in this course?
No?
So if your trip to--
we're going to talk more about
it later than we will here.
But if your trip to--
[WRITING ON BOARD]
OK, so you know that running
times are stochastic, right?
So there's a distribution
of running times.
So this is running time,
or in this case let's
call it journey time.
And this is a probability
[INAUDIBLE],, right?
So the schedule has to have
a single intrinsic value.
And you can go to
your journey planner,
and it will say your
journey takes this long.
You walk this much time,
you wait this much time,
you arrive at this time.
So you add those components up
and you have a specific time.
That specific time may be close
to the median, and may not.
So if service is
reliable, then there's
little variance in this
distribution, correct?
So you might have--
I don't have much of
another color here.
That doesn't work.
So I'll just write
on white as well.
Maybe a dot.
So you might have one
distribution of journeys
that has lower variance.
And therefore you need to budget
less time to make your trip
and arrive on time.
Correct?
So to the extent
that the waiting is
variable or your in-vehicle
time is variable, then
if you need to be at work
or at school at 9:00 AM,
that means that, even if on
average it takes half an hour,
you might have to
budget for 45 minutes.
So the extra 15 minutes of time
that you budget, that's called
the reliability buffer.
It's a cost.
You could monetize
it if you wanted to.
It means that people are
budgeting, and in some cases
wasting, that time.
And we want to decrease that.
So the need for trip
time reliability buffer.
Higher loads.
So that means, of
course, that vehicles
have more people in
them, and therefore rides
are more uncomfortable
for passengers.
And they are also slower,
because if a vehicle has
more people in it, the
bus stops more often
and the process is slower.
We know that from
earlier lectures.
We know from random incidents
that from a passenger
perspective, passengers
will experience
more crowded
vehicles because they
are more likely to
board the vehicle
where there are
more people in it.
It's a little bit of a
chicken and egg problem.
So even if, on average
across the vehicles,
your loads are right
where they should be,
most people are going to be
on the more crowded vehicles.
So that's that thing.
In terms of agency impacts
can increase costs, making,
for example, you need a longer
recovery time at the terminal.
And therefore, you know
that that translates
to higher vehicle costs, higher
crew costs, reduced ridership
and revenue, reduced
operator morale, a public
and political problem.
What do we mean by that?
What happens when
public transportation
is unreliable in
terms of politics?
AUDIENCE: The public hates it.
Public hates unreliability.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It creates pressure.
The forces against public
transportation grows stronger.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Sure.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
funding, and then--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah,
so there's a funding, right?
And we'll talk more about
this in the last two lectures.
So when public
transportation is unreliable,
sometimes governments
are hesitant,
or the public may be
hesitant, to fund it more
before they fix the problems.
But fixing the problems
might require some resources.
So it's a vicious cycle.
And then reduced
effective capacity.
And we'll show a real example
here in Boston of that.
All right.
So what causes this?
We can divide causes into
external and internal causes.
External causes.
Traffic, demand-- demand
variability in particular--
incidents.
So a passenger may get sick.
These things are external.
The agency knows that
they could happen,
but there's not much
you can do about them.
Internal causes are in
the control of the agency,
at least a little more.
So equipment failure, that's
something that agency owns.
Maybe you can't predict
exactly when it will happen,
but with some
preventive maintenance
they could reduce the
chance of this happening.
Insufficient resources,
poor operations planning,
lack of supervision and control,
and human driver behavior.
What do I mean by
human driver behavior?
How does that cause
unreliability?
Henry.
AUDIENCE: The way that
a driver drives can vary
and that affects runtime.
Or maybe some are more
aggressive and some are less.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
Some drivers are slow,
some drivers are fast.
And then if you're running
high-frequency service,
they'll bunch up.
And that could be the
cause of bunching.
Or maybe that fast driver is
now running early, rolling
a long headway service early.
And that's really bad for
waiting time, as we'll see.
So if we think about
transit, and look
at the whole process of
planning it and delivering it
as if it were a
business process,
we know that we start
with service planning,
and move on to
operations planning,
and then actual operations.
And each of these
things, the output of one
is the input to the next
process, and so forth.
The input to service
policy, among them are
is demand estimation.
Then we bring in analysis of
models or vehicle scheduling
and crew scheduling.
And during operations
there's service control.
We'll talk about service
control, real-time control,
too, as an input to operations,
to make them more reliable.
So there's also a feedback
loop, because passengers
might complain or somehow
you have data collecting
information on performance.
And you can take that back to
service planning or operations
planning, or you could
modify your service control
to change the cycle.
And here we have the key
agents in each of these steps.
So transit agency
management, mostly
taking care of service policy.
Then you have some
operational planning stuff,
taking care of
operations planning.
And then the actual drivers and
inspectors out in the field.
So I guess one
thing to take away
from this is that there are
many decisions across all
of this process that
affect reliability.
And you can't really have
reliable service if you--
there's many places
where you could--
a cause on reliability.
One of them might be
your vehicles break down.
So no matter what
you do, if your fleet
is old and having
difficulty with maintenance,
you might have the
best service control
policies, and all the
supervision in the world,
and you still have
unreliable service.
So it's a hard problem.
It used to be very
hard, actually,
because, well, to
ensure reliability you
need to ensure the
variability and things.
So you know from data
collection that if you
want to measure the mean, you
can calculate your sample size.
Measuring the
variance of something
requires an even greater
data collection effort.
So things have gotten a
lot easier with technology.
And so we know that we have
several data collection
systems--
AVL, AFC, APC.
That makes it a lot easier and
cheaper to measure reliability.
We'll give some examples.
Then we have scheduling
systems, which
make it very easy to make an
adjustment in the schedule.
If we see that we've not
scheduled enough time
for this bus, we need
to add some recovery
time, that's going to increase
the fleet size by one.
With a program or
scheduling software,
you can do that
quickly and react.
And the best systems will
actually read AVL data in,
and you don't even have
to manually analyze it.
You can sort of use the
program to analyze it.
And the same program
will help you schedule.
And then there's improved
communications technology,
which makes it easy to
communicate instructions.
Hey, depart a little
later from this stop,
or from this terminal.
Don't, you know, start
running without passengers.
And start operating in
revenue service three
stops down because
we have a long gap.
So you may have heard, you
can't really have control--
there are so many
ways of saying things,
but you can't really do
something about something
until you measure it.
So measuring it is important.
We'll talk a little
bit about reliability
as a performance metric.
And there are different
key performance indicators
you can calculate
for reliability,
and that's the first step.
You want to measure
it and you want
to be able to track
your reliability
for particular routes
or system wide,
and then be able to change a
policy, see what the effect is.
So one thing about
it is it's not
the only thing that matters.
Reliability is important.
It would be a mistake
not to measure it.
Because you might have a
very productive service,
but you might have all of these
problems that we identified.
On the other hand, if you put
too much focus on reliability,
then it would come at a cost.
If you want to make your
schedule very reliable,
then you can add a
lot of recovery time.
And you could add
many timing points
and make the buses
hold everywhere,
and that would
slow service down.
It would increase journey times.
Even if they would
be very predictable,
they would be very long, and
that could deteriorate service.
So we make a distinction between
reliability on low frequency
service and reliability
on high frequency service.
What's the difference?
We've talked about
the waiting strategies
for low and high frequency.
We've talked about it
several times before.
[CHUCKLES]
What's the difference between
a service that runs every 20
minutes and a service that runs
every five minutes with regards
to your strategy to
take that service?
AUDIENCE: It's more frequent
and you can just walk up.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, so high frequency service
is walk-up service.
AUDIENCE: No random arrivals.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
The arrivals tend to be random.
They don't actually have
to be for this distinction
to be valid.
They have to be independent
of the vehicle arrivals.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
Yes, we'll mention that.
So with low frequency
service, most people
will time their arrival
at stops so that they
are with the schedule.
So if vehicles are
arriving on schedule,
and passengers are
people wait very little time.
And if there's very little
variability in that,
if service is
incredibly punctual,
people would show up the minute
before and wait almost nothing.
If there's some
variability, then people
have to add some
reliability buffer time.
So even though it says
it's going to come at 3:53,
you might have to
get there at 3:50.
OK.
So you then can set--
because you want to measure
reliability, people--
especially in the US, we call
that on-time performance,
which is a long way
of saying punctuality.
You could have different
wait threshold windows.
And we've talked about
performance measurement before.
We're just here, so we're
going back to specifically
reliability.
One way would be to
say, any bus that
departs this stop between one
minute early and five minutes
late is on time.
And any bus outside of
that window is not on time.
And then you say,
I am 90% reliable.
This bus leaves that stop 90%
of the time within that window.
And then you could
have tighter windows.
You could say, not early and
up to three minutes late,
or not early and up
to one minute late.
Of course what happens--
well, let's start
with the first one.
What's wrong with the first one?
What's different
about the first one?
You allow early departures.
What's bad about early
departures when you
have a long headway service?
AUDIENCE: People
aren't expecting it
and they miss their bus.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Right.
So if people are really timing
their arrival at the stops
according to the schedule, and
it's 20-minute headway service,
bus leaves early.
You arrived a minute early.
Now you have to wait 20 minutes.
It's really bad.
Really bad.
This thing is a little--
real-time apps help with this,
but not everyone has one.
And if service tends
to be reliable,
and every now and then it isn't,
then people might still have--
they're trying to show
up to work on time.
So there's not much the
app can do unless there's
a good warning ahead
of time, this bus
is going to come early.
You'd better be there.
So you have to
rush to get ready.
OK.
So it's good to not
allow early departures.
What happens when
you move to tighter
bounds on the late side?
Two things happen.
AUDIENCE: Harder to meet it.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So it's harder to meet.
And that means that your
reported reliability
comes down.
So you can imagine, internally,
a pressure on the agency
to have a little more
slack, to say that you
have higher reliability.
What happens in
terms of performance,
or in terms of waiting time,
benefit for the passenger?
If the agency actually has a
holding policy that prevents
a bus from departing late--
more than five minutes late,
more than three minutes late,
more than one minute late--
from a stop in the middle
of the route with people
inside of it, what happens is
you move to tighter windows.
AUDIENCE: The
driver will be less
lenient in holding the bus
for people running after it?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Especially if you're--
right, tighter window on the
early side, more holding.
AUDIENCE: Like, sorry,
we've got to go.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So how do you make
the bus not be late?
What's the strategy for that?
AUDIENCE: You schedule in more--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: You
don't schedule for median.
You schedule for a
higher percentile.
So now it's easy, piece of cake.
You schedule it for 80
percentile, only 20%
of the time will you be--
OK, but what happens?
That means that 80% of the
time you're arriving early,
so you have to hold.
So as you make that
window tighter,
it means that you're
probably going to be
setting your percentile higher.
And it means that you'll
be holding more often
and slowing service down.
And holding is very
frustrating for passengers.
So you shouldn't hold
always and for a long time.
And in general, I guess
one other comment is
like any kind of window,
especially on the later side,
the benefits of going from
five to three to one minutes
are going to be marginal
in terms of waiting.
And they can be
substantial in terms
of how often you'll
have to hold it
and how slow the
service will be.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Why is holding more
often if you're--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: If
you have a tighter window.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
if you have a tighter window--
if your vehicle must depart
between zero minutes early
and one minute late, it's
a very tight window, right?
So how can you guarantee
that that vehicle departs
that stop in the window?
You have to schedule it such
that it almost always arrives--
you have to allow a lot
of time on the schedule
so that almost
always it can arrive,
and it's not arriving
one minute late.
AUDIENCE: Ah, all right.
[INAUDIBLE] time.
So you're--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So you control the late side
by scheduling more time.
And then what happens
on the early side?
On the early side, if
you arrive early, you--
AUDIENCE: You just sit there.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You have to sit there.
OK.
So in long headway service,
or low frequency service,
there is a little interaction
between successive vehicles,
so bunching is not
a normal thing.
So we'll talk about bunching in
the context of high frequency
service.
And then, of course, real time
information is changing this.
So now you have an app.
And your app, as you're doing
your breakfast, phone vibrates
and says, here's the time.
Here's my predicted time.
So you rush.
Maybe you'll skip something
on breakfast or you'll--
I don't know.
So that is very
poorly understood
from a research standpoint.
We don't really know how
exactly that happens,
what percentage of people are
actually changing when they
would arrive based on the app.
And we don't really know
what the implications are.
Because you can't just say--
imagine if everybody had an app,
and everybody used that app.
And you're running
20-minute headway service.
Now you say, well,
everybody is going
to show up to time the
arrival at the stop.
So let's not worry at
all about reliability.
It doesn't matter when vehicles
come because people know
and they time their arrivals.
So now we can speed up service.
But there is some sense
of convenience of knowing
that it runs every 20 minutes.
The availability of
service every 20 minutes
is a factor that wouldn't be
considered if you did that.
So in some way, it
is still important
even if people can time
their arrival at stops,
to keep service as scheduled
when it's long headway.
And we don't really--
how do you measure that?
How you quantify that
convenience, that coverage?
All questions for researchers.
AUDIENCE: So is there--
for this time window, is
there a defined threshold
to define something that
is a very tight time frame?
Like median, long, and
tight time frame for this?
And when does it matter?
Because obviously, tight is
different in the mornings
when you have [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: This
is-- that decisions are up
to the agency?
AUDIENCE: It's up to the agency.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
And usually there's
a trade-off where
you want to set a goal
that is attainable.
You don't want to be
reporting 30% reliability.
So it's a bar that moves
according to the abilities
of the agency, usually.
That's what happens in practice.
If there are no more questions
on low frequency service,
let's move to high
frequency service.
A little more interesting.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What's the cut off there
between high frequency
and low frequency?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Good question.
So what do you think?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
That is a good point.
He said it depends
which country you're in.
That's a very
legitimate observation.
So it's not just US and non-US.
It's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Urban, rural.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Here in the US,
here in Boston, what
would you consider
to be high frequency service?
AUDIENCE: Up to
10-minute headways.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
10 minutes?
AUDIENCE: Up to 10 minutes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, certainly
not more than that.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
If it's 12 minutes,
do you look at the schedule?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] divides
it as 15 and [INAUDIBLE]
going up to 16 and 17.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
yeah, some agencies say 15.
In London, I think it's 12.
I think that's the cutoff.
Now, if you go to
Chile and you say
that you're running
10 minute, they
think of that as long
headway service-- very long.
Because they have buses
that run every minute.
So that's high frequency, and
seven minutes is low frequency.
So that's a
distinction, at least
from an operational standpoint,
that people make differently
in every country.
But in terms of
waiting time strategy,
I think it still holds that it's
somewhere between 10 and 15.
Maybe between 8 and 15.
We don't know.
Obviously, there's a continuum.
It's not like everybody switches
at exactly some threshold.
It depends on the person, and
what technology they have,
and what service they're taking.
Between those 8 and 15
minutes, or even 12 minutes,
there's going to be a transition
from one strategy to the other.
And you know that when you're
well in the high frequency
zone, your models of random,
or at least independent,
arrivals of passengers
at stops hold.
Whereas as you move towards 15
and longer, they stop holding
and you shouldn't be measuring
waiting time like this.
AUDIENCE: I was asking
that because, even
with 10 minutes, which is
considered high frequency,
I still want to schedule
myself for when I'm
going to get to the bus stop.
I'm not just like, oh, let
me just walk to the bus stop
and I'll wait.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So for 10
minutes, do you actually
consult the schedule?
AUDIENCE: Well, I consult
the app for 10 minutes.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
But do you
plan to take the 9:10 train?
Or-- you see, there's a
distinction, like the day
before, you know I'm
going to take the 9:10
AUDIENCE: If they were running
clock-based, consistent
10-minute headways,
then I would.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Then you would show up.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
But they're not.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So for you,
10 is right there on the fence
between the two, it seems.
More on the scheduled side,
on the high frequency side,
perhaps.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
But let's say that
it's five minutes.
So now we're clear
on that vague area.
So now you're in a zone
where most people will
time their arrivals at
stops-- sorry, will not
time their arrivals at stops.
They will show up
when convenient.
And they expect to wait
about half of the headway.
You know that if the
headways are variable,
you're going to have that
waiting time increasing.
So there's going to be a
reliability buffer time
calculation that you can do.
And it's going to be the
coefficient variation
of headway, will sort of affect.
That's the factor that sort of
increases the expected waiting
time.
Punctuality is not as
critical for the passengers.
They don't really
care if every train
is five minutes
late, as long as they
come in every five minutes.
It doesn't really matter that
they're all five minutes late.
So really, what
matters for a passenger
is bunching and long gaps.
We've talked about that before.
We know that in high
frequency service,
there is a lot of
vehicle interaction.
We can maybe review it quickly.
Think of this as a bus route.
And here's a vehicle.
Each of these are vehicles.
And there's a random
arrival process.
Passengers are arriving
randomly at the different stops.
So what happens when vehicles
are not evenly spaced in time,
not in space.
So what happens when
they're not evenly spaced?
AUDIENCE: The one that's close
to the next one picks up less?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, so this vehicle
has a smaller gap ahead of it.
And therefore, because
people are arriving
at some rate, in that
time, for that rate,
fewer passengers will
be taking this bus.
And that means that
real times are shorter.
Vehicle catches up.
So now you have a bunch.
Eventually this vehicle
will catch up to this one.
If this vehicle,
the one ahead of it,
has a long headway ahead of
it, the opposite happens.
More people than average
arrive, and then that vehicle
has many more people in it.
The loads increase.
It slows down.
So those two effects work
together to create bunching.
And we've talked about that.
And with bunching, the
counterpart is long gaps.
You usually have a bunch
and then a long gap.
Or a long gap preceding a bunch.
So you'll hear
passengers complaining,
I've been waiting 15 minutes,
and now three buses arrive,
as if that were ironic.
But that's actually
exactly why it happens.
AUDIENCE: So what's the best
strategy to deal with bunching?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
We'll talk about many of them.
Yeah.
OK, so one observation is
that some high frequency
routes have branches.
So they're only high
frequency in the trunk,
and the individual branches
are actually long headway.
And there, you have to
run scheduled service
on the branches.
And then you have
to, I guess, try
to run scheduled
service on the trunk.
There might be some
hybrid strategies,
but that's still the
subject of research.
And of course, schedule
control is much easier
than headway control.
You can do it
without technology.
You can print a
schedule, and the driver
can have the schedule
in the vehicle.
And you can tell drivers,
don't leave early.
And if they follow instructions,
they won't leave early.
So if you want to
control headways,
and you want to keep the
vehicles evenly spaced,
now you need all this
technology infrastructure
to detect where vehicles
are, to predict the running
times between them, and to
communicate instructions
to those vehicles so that
the headways can be adjusted.
Here's a little
reliability buffer time.
So let's talk about how
to actually calculate it
in a high frequency,
closed fare system.
So think of the London Tube.
You tap in the station, and
then you tap out when you leave.
So you can measure the
probability distribution
of travel time, or of journey
time, from tap-in time
to tap-out time.
And we define the
reliability buffer time
as the difference between
the 95th percentile
and the 50th percentile
of that journey time.
So again, if this distribution
were much narrower,
then people would not have to
budget that difference as they
plan to make a trip, to arrive
at a certain time at work
or school.
Something interesting
about this is
that London has somewhat
recently started
refunding fares if
people's journeys exceed
30 minutes of the expected.
So they're not doing it
by percentile, but they--
so here's an application
in fare policy,
which is not the
most obvious one.
But you can certainly
measure this reliability
of buffer time.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
how much it costs them?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: No.
I don't think much.
Well, it is a lot in total.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't remember
what percent of passengers.
I think the percent
is quite low,
except if there's a big
disruption it might be high.
But because of the sheer
size of the network,
I'm sure that that adds up, too.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's a good
marketing strategy.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Builds confidence.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
London, they
don't talk so much passengers.
They talk about their customers.
And they want to have
customer service.
And so they like to have
that internal mentality.
AUDIENCE: Well, how do they
know someone wasn't dwelling
at a station as a passenger?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Because they
can look at other people
doing that same trip.
So if somebody
wants to hang out,
they're not going
to get a free trip
just because they wanted to.
AUDIENCE: It's interesting.
In the daily metro,
to prevent crowding,
if you spend too much
time in the system,
they actually give you a
penalty when you tap out.
And so some of the
journeys are so long,
people actually have
to rush to get out,
or else they suffer
a [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Not very good reliability.
We can add that to the list.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do they determine
the expected journey time?
Is it median--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They look at this--
so they measure this.
And I'll show you
the next slide.
Before we move on
to the next slide,
any other questions on this one?
I saw several hands raised.
OK.
So they look at good
days and bad days,
to answer your question.
So they pick some
baseline of days
that have no major disruptions,
service is running well.
It's the amount
that they expect.
And then they'll measure
reliability buffer time
on those days.
So that is an
amount that they say
is sort of inherent
to the operation
and not much under their
control, unless they invest
in better signaling systems
or things like this.
Anything in excess of
that, if you look at,
now, all days together,
will be something
that they could have avoided.
That's the idea.
This distinction between
the baseline buffer time
and the access buffer time.
So if that x as buffer
time exceeds some amount,
you can then say, well,
we have a problem.
Passengers were taking much
longer than we scheduled for,
or that we thought they
could take, and therefore
let's refund the fare,
because it was bad service.
AUDIENCE: This is for
[INAUDIBLE] on the Victoria
Line?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yes.
Northbound?
You mean this graph?
AUDIENCE: Mhm.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So northbound, southbound, yeah.
And the reference is right here.
David Uniman, 2009, so you can
check it out in the library
if you're interested.
OK, so what happens
when it's low frequency.
Now people are not
arriving necessarily
to randomly or independent now.
They might actually be
scheduling their arrival
to meet a particular train.
But of course, trains may
not be running on schedule.
So you have this
space-time diagram here.
We have time on the horizontal
and space, or the stations,
on the vertical.
And you see that
there is some degree
of variability in timing.
And if these vehicles
were on time, maybe
they would be more
evenly spaced.
So we have taps.
Here, there's a
touch in at 8:00.
And so what we do is that we
look at what's the next train?
When does that tap
in aboard, and that's
how much they waited.
You're comparing to
scheduled departure,
which is in this case 8:06.
So because the train--
I don't know if I'm
explaining this clearly.
So you can match the
tap-in time to the closest
scheduled departure that
follows that tap in.
And that's the train that
the person intends to board.
And that's how much
the person intends--
the difference between those
two times is the amount of time
that the person intends to
wait or expects to wait.
Any waiting time beyond
that is excess waiting time.
And then you're going to do the
same for the in-vehicle time.
That's where
[INAUDIBLE] and that's
how you get reliability
buffer time.
So you're now considering the
waiting strategy is different.
And here's the reference.
2010, another thesis.
For bus, there's
another challenge.
Well, there's two challenges.
The first one is we
need to distinguish
between the performance
of the contractor,
if it's a private operator
and you're paying the bus
company to run service for
you, and the performance
as the passenger sees it.
So as it says on the bottom,
if service is unreliable,
the passenger doesn't
care why it's unreliable.
But the operator
needs to know if it's
the fault of the
operator or if it
was an external
reason that was not
under the control
of the operator.
Why?
Why is that important?
Henry.
AUDIENCE: If there is traffic,
then there could likely
be traffic downstream, as well.
And you would continue
to be on the line
for the remainder of the trip.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
But you're thinking
of a specific trip.
Because I'm thinking
more generally.
So why would the agency
want to distinguish
between bad performance that
can be assigned or blamed
on the operator versus bad
performance that is exogenous.
AUDIENCE: Because
if the bad service
is due to some act of
God, then the agency maybe
can't hold the
contractor accountable.
But if the contract and service
provider did something wrong,
then there can be some
kind of punishment.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
OK, yes.
And in this case, a
punishment under the contract
might be a penalty.
So they might withhold some--
if there's a performance bonus,
maybe the operator
does not get that bonus
when there might be actually
provisions for a penalty.
Or a discount on the payment.
And it doesn't have
to be an act of God.
It can be normal traffic.
And the variability
in travel times
that is expected
because of traffic
that is not under the
control of the operator.
But what if the operator is
not maintaining his buses
and some vehicles have
to be put out of service?
So the operator drops trips and
now performance is not as good.
That is very clearly the
fault of the operator,
and you want to
penalize the operator.
So that's one challenge.
So you have to
measure reliability,
but you might have to
assign its sources.
You might have to calculate
the sources of those
and sort of assign cost codes
to whatever you measure.
And there might be a mix.
The other challenge is that
typically, buses are only
tap on and not tap off.
So you have to--
journey time includes
the in-vehicle portion.
So now you have to
figure out where
this person alights to figure
out the in-vehicle component.
And waiting time is
another portion of this,
and the passenger
doesn't tap in until they
have finished waiting.
So you have to go back and
calculate, how long did they
wait?
So those are two
minor challenges.
Here's a strategy.
For destinations, we have ODX.
So we can look at
their next tap in.
We can do trip chaining,
as we discussed previously,
and infer the destination
for that person.
And for some people
that will fail,
but we can scale
up in probability.
We can say, well, if this
person didn't have a next tap,
let's look at the
distribution of passengers
who do have an
next tap and let's
assume that these other
people have destinations
that are in proportion--
distributed in the
same way as people
who have destinations inferred.
And then from AVL, we can
sort of do the same trick
that we did for rail.
We can assume that there is
some process by which passengers
arrive at stops.
So if it's high-frequency
bus service,
we say it's some arrival rate.
If it's low
frequency service, we
say they arrive on time
to match the schedule.
And then we can compare that
with actual vehicle times.
So if we have an
assumption about when
the passenger arrived, then we
can calculate the difference
and measure the waiting time.
So it's more
stochastic because we
don't know exactly when
this person arrived.
But in probability, you
know that in aggregate,
across all passengers,
any one person arrived
between this bus and that bus.
So yeah.
Questions about this process
for measuring journey time
reliability?
Comments?
AUDIENCE: One man complained
about waiting time, it's
like with the bus.
Like, oh, with
the scheduled bus,
if the person only waits
one minute, that's great.
But if I'm waiting at my
desk for eight minutes,
I actually was--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So that it
goes back to the
discussion about apps
that we had just
a few minutes ago,
that you can't just say
that because there are apps,
then we can just run
service unreliably
if it's long headway.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So if it's high frequency,
you probably won't care.
You'll just still go.
Or you'll be timing it, but you
would have arrived randomly,
anyway, to some extent,
i.e. your intention
to begin the trip is random,
or at least independent
of the schedule.
But if it's long headway
service, then yes,
you maybe stay at your desk
or get a cup of coffee.
But you're still inconvenienced.
And so there's a penalty for it.
AUDIENCE: Right.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And we need to figure out
how to measure it.
And one way is to assume
that people still arrive,
or want to arrive, on time.
And that's what we've been
doing because that's what we
used to do, and kind of works.
But it's slightly different.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
use the stochastic process
to estimate wait time?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
So let's-- another timeline.
So in this case it's a
timeline, not a space line.
So let's say that there's
a tap at that time.
And the buses are
arriving here, here, here.
Sorry.
Well, the tap has to be
when the bus arrives,
or very close to it.
Because the person is
tapping in at the bus.
So what you know
for this person,
assuming that this
bus isn't full,
is that that person
arrived as late
as exactly when that
vehicle arrived,
and as early as this vehicle.
So you know that
the arrival time
of that person and the time
at which they began waiting,
is a stochastic variable
with a uniform distribution
on that range.
And you know the mean
of that distribution
is half the headway.
So if the bus arrivals
are high frequency
and the person is
arriving randomly,
then this is certainly true.
If it's long headway
service, then you
have to then consider what
the scheduled times were.
So now you have to do a
process similar to what
we did for rail, where--
let me just draw it here.
So if this bus was
meant to arrive here,
then maybe you say,
well, this person
must have been wanting
to get on that bus.
And so you made them
wait some extra time.
And then if this bus was
scheduled to depart here,
then you know that
bus was early.
So that means that some
of the people that end up
tapping in here were probably
trying to get on this bus
and they missed it.
Because they arrived
between this and this time--
between the actual
and the departed time.
So those are the people
who suffer the most.
And that's more
difficult to calculate.
You might have to assume
some proportion of the people
you see here.
You could compare
to a typical load
and see if there's
an excess, and assume
that that excess would have
been on the previous bus,
if that bus had
departed on time.
So you have to use
more assumptions.
OK.
So we understand how to measure
reliability for rail tap ins
and tap outs, long headway,
short headway, and for bus.
So strategies.
So the question Eli had earlier
was, what do we do about it?
Now we can measure it.
So if you can measure something,
you do something about it.
What can we do about it?
So two kinds of things.
We can use preventive strategies
and corrective strategies.
Preventive strategies are aimed
at maintaining normal service
and having some robust
operations plans that
can handle unreliability
without having a domino effect,
where everything cascades
into unreliability.
And that it reduces
the probability
that problems occur.
Corrective strategies
are you know,
you're monitoring the system,
you see unreliability,
and you do something to the
system at that time to fix it,
to make it more
reliable and to minimize
the impact on passengers.
So examples of
preventive strategies
are having reserve fleet
of drivers and vehicles.
If a driver is sick,
you have another driver
and you send that driver.
Vehicle is not operating,
you have another vehicle.
Having exclusive bus lanes.
So if you have great
separation, you
get rid of some of
the unreliability that
comes from traffic.
Traffic signal
priority-- sorry, that
should be transit
signal priority.
We talked about that in
our previous lecture.
There are route
design strategies.
So we know.
We've seen that longer routes
are more reliable because they
have more time between recovery
time, between layovers,
essentially.
They have fewer stops.
So there's less of a dwell
time unreliability effect.
You can make schedules that
have a good amount of recovery
at the end.
So you look at the
percentiles and you
make sure that you're
not picking the average
to calculate your cycle times.
And you set the timing
points at good percentiles.
Maybe it's the median, maybe
it's the 40th percentile.
And of course,
hiring supervisors
to make sure that your
people are showing up
and they're leaving on time
rather than whenever they want,
et cetera.
So it's schedules.
So two critical decisions-- the
cycle time, we know about that.
We know that it impacts cost
and the reliability of departure
time of the terminal.
And you're very
familiar with that,
I think, by now, so I don't
have to spend as much time
discussing it.
Timing points is another.
So you can, in the middle of a
bus route, have timing points.
So we know that there
might be a terminal here
and a terminal here.
And whenever a bus
arrives at the end to be,
they then have a
layover to catch up.
We know that from
assignment one, even.
But you can actually
have points in the middle
where buses are also not
allowed to leave early.
And so if you schedule the
times of these in some way,
then buses might hold
more or hold less,
and they will depart
those points on time.
Where should you put those
timing points, if at all?
AUDIENCE: Inter-transfers?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So one idea is that if there's
a big train station here
or another bus line
that also runs--
especially for low
frequency service--
and people want to connect,
they need to transfer,
and they want to connect.
You might actually have a
timing point for both routes
there so the vehicles meet and
people can switch vehicles.
So that's one idea.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Maybe after a high
variability section, like after
[INAUDIBLE]?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So maybe this lane
has a lot of traffic
and it's causing a
lot of unreliability.
So you want to take
care of it there instead
of letting it cascade into more
variable headways, for example.
What else?
AUDIENCE: High demand,
those stations.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
High-demand stations.
OK.
So what about demand?
Demand is important,
but what exactly?
AUDIENCE: I mean, if the bus is
reliable at that stations, then
the passengers--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
What do you mean?
For example, a lot of people
getting off from this bus
to take that station, or to
enter that train station, or--
AUDIENCE: People are getting
onto the bus at that station.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So right upstream of sections
where there are many boardings.
That's a very important
thing because that's
where most people benefit.
And what else?
What else about passengers?
Where would you not
want to do this?
Harry.
AUDIENCE: When the bus is full?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
When the bus is full.
So if your load profile looks--
I don't know.
A lot of people get on here.
And they're mostly
not getting off.
And they sort of
come down like that.
Do you want timing
points on that bus route?
You don't.
You don't want timing points
because most people are
getting on here and they don't
want to be held here and here.
And very few people might
be boarding in this section.
So if you hold a
timing point, you're
going to benefit few
passengers and penalize,
by longer and more frustrating
vehicle rides, many passengers.
So what if there's a big
transfer station here,
and a lot of people
transfer, and then
here there's another station
and a lot of people get on.
So then this is a good place
to have a timing point,
right before a lot
of people board
and when you don't have
many people on the bus.
The flow profile is low.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] liability
before that [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Exactly.
So you want to maximize the
segment of the population that
will benefit from the
strategy and minimize
the segment of the
population that
will be hurt by the strategy,
i.e. people in the bus.
OK.
So that's a word about number
and location of timing points.
And then the schedule
at each timing point.
What should you set
the percentile at?
Should this be the median?
Should they be 80 percentile?
Should they be 30 percentile?
AUDIENCE: The median realm.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So what happens if you--
how many vehicles
will have to be held?
What percent of
vehicles will have
to be held if you set
it to 80th percentile?
AUDIENCE: Oh, 80%.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: 80%.
OK.
So 80% of vehicles would be sort
of getting here and waiting.
That may be acceptable if,
again, very few people are here
and a lot of people
are boarding.
What if it's more of a mix?
Then you want to
bring that down.
You dial it down.
So some people say
set the half cycle
to somewhere between
90% and 95%--
we've done that-- and then
set timing points at 65.
I actually prefer that the
timing points are below 50.
Because then you can
advertise to your passengers.
You're essentially lying
to people and saying--
you're motivating people to
arrive earlier than, most
often, the vehicle arrives.
So their probability
of arriving and missing
a vehicle that
departed early is lower
because you're telling them,
expect an early departure,
essentially.
Except you don't call it early.
You say that's when it's
scheduled to arrive.
So essentially you
can control this
by scheduling a certain way,
and then on the other side
by controlling it.
AUDIENCE: But the pushback
when people are like,
oh, the bus is
always running late.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yeah, so it affects--
there's a balance.
I'm not saying, schedule
it 10th percentile.
But I think a little below
50 is a good strategy.
Because then you would
minimize holding.
You would only
hold vehicles that
are really early, essentially.
And holding is frustrating.
You don't want to be
doing it all the time.
So by scheduling at
a lower percentile,
you don't hold as often.
And you don't hold
for as long times.
All right.
You have to be careful
when you do this,
when you have timing points.
Because then your AVL
data will come in,
and you're going to say,
what's the running time?
Well, if people are
following your instructions,
the minimum running
time will be whatever
your timing points are.
So maybe your distribution
would look like this.
But because you
have timing points,
you've chopped off
the early portion.
And now it looks more like this.
And now your 95th percentile
is more to the right
than it used to be, maybe.
Maybe not.
Maybe it stays where it is.
But you have to be
careful with this.
Your average will certainly
move to the right.
So just be careful about that.
One strategy is to distinguish
holding from running,
but that's a little
difficult with AVL sometimes.
Another strategy is to run a
month without timing points,
essentially instruct
your drivers not
to use timing points, and
collect data for a month,
and then use that for planning.
So just the things we can do.
OK, now corrective strategies.
So obviously, supervision.
Having supervisors, having an
operations control practice
is important.
There's different strategies.
This is one of my favorite
topics in transit.
So holding-- you can do holding
to schedule or to headway.
So what is holding to schedule?
That's a simple one.
We've mentioned
it a dozen times,
and even in this lecture.
You don't allow a vehicle to
depart early from a timing
point or from a terminal.
So if a vehicle arrives a
minute early at a timing point,
you instruct that driver
to hold one minute.
Even though that bus
is able to move on,
that bus holds for one minute.
TSP we talked about.
What's deadheading?
AUDIENCE: Just moving
a bus from one place
to another that's not
a revenue [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: OK.
So let's say that
you have buses here,
and this is your terminal.
And there's a bus that
you are about to depart.
And your headway, the scheduled
headway is more like this.
So you were supposed to have
a bus here, but you didn't.
Something happened and
the bus wasn't there.
And now you have two buses
there instead of one.
Maybe there was a
bunching on the way back
and the bunch arrived late,
as it usually happens.
So one strategy that you can
use is to take the first one
and instruct a deadhead
to somewhere around here.
So this bus would run
without its head sign
on, not allowing
anybody to board--
and that's why it's
called a deadhead--
to this stop.
And then this bus
departs immediately,
but it remains in service.
So if that deadhead can
happen quickly, maybe not even
following the
streets or the bus,
maybe there's a faster way.
And you inject it downstream.
You can speed things up, you
can balance the headways.
What's expressing?
AUDIENCE: Skipping stops?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: That's
one way of doing expressions.
Expressing can be done
from the terminal.
So the distinction between
expressing and deadheading
is that expressing them
with people inside.
So in this case, you
could have allowed people
to board at the
terminal and then said,
we're going to run express.
You tell people
who are boarding,
we're going to run express.
So if you're getting off
anywhere between here and here,
don't board.
And the vehicle then skips
stops, but with people inside.
So I don't think I need to
do a drawing for this one.
Expressing can also be
done halfway through.
So if you have this
situation, then you
could say these people
might have boarded, not
knowing that this bus was
going to be expressed,
but something happened.
Maybe the driver was slow.
Maybe there was some traffic
accident and there were delays.
So you can then announce
this bus is being expressed,
or this train is
being expressed,
and we're going to skip
the following three stops
and arrive somewhere.
So if you're getting
off before the express,
you have to decide,
are you going
to stay and then walk back?
Are you going to stay and then
take transit the opposite way?
Or are you going to
get off right now
and wait for the next vehicle?
So it's a higher
penalty for passengers.
What about short term?
We've talked about all of these,
but in the context of planning.
And now we're using them
for real time control.
So this is deadheading.
[WRITING ON BOARD]
Right.
And then yeah, so short term.
[WRITING ON BOARD]
Here's the situation.
You have-- this doesn't happen
often, but it does happen.
You have a bunch
in one direction
and a very long gap in
the other direction.
And what happens with bunching?
The bus behind is
usually not very full.
So you stop these
buses and say stop.
And you tell the people here
to move to the bus ahead.
Get off the bus.
We're in short term.
We're going to
terminate the trip here.
And those people will have
to transfer to the next bus.
If you don't allow
this to happen,
then it's really
onerous for passengers
because they have to get off
and wait for the next one.
So it's better if you
coordinate it this way.
And then this bus gets sent
here and begins operating
in the opposite direction.
AUDIENCE: How much of
this is done automatically
versus a person
looking at this--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I don't know of any case
where this is done
automatically.
There has been researchers here
at MIT and elsewhere, including
me, who have tried to
write algorithms that
detect these opportunities.
But I don't know of any
real implementation.
London buses does this,
or at least they used to.
I think they still do.
But they really try
to coordinate this.
They very rarely curtail
trips without coordinating
in a bunch.
Because then people have
to wait for the next one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] as well.
GABRIEL
SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: The train
systems [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yeah.
Yes.
So in trains, it's more common.
But it's usually a person in
a control center determining
that they want to do this.
AUDIENCE: What's stopping them
from [INAUDIBLE] algorithms?
Is it that the algorithms
are not good enough or--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That's part of it.
And then yeah.
I think I would say
that's part of it.
The other is maybe
a lack of interest
or a lack of faith
in the computer.
There's a system in place.
It's just, you know, it's hard.
AUDIENCE: But there are two
elements to this problem.
One is that you have to detect
a problem in one direction.
And the other thing
is that you have
to detect an opportunity
in the other direction.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
this doesn't happen very often.
AUDIENCE: There
are two parts here
that are completely
independent from each other.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
They're not independent,
though.
If the route is long
you actually have--
even though in a short
route, in any given segment,
the probability
of this happening
is low, if you have a long
route it's much higher.
It's like the point you brought
up with Professor Fritz'
lecture, you said, oh, the
chances of a bus benefiting
from this are very small.
And then you said, well,
what if it's a long route
and there are 20 signals?
Same thing applies here.
You might have a long
route with many windows,
and the chances that there
is one window at any given
time in the rush hour
is actually pretty high.
AUDIENCE: And then the other
thing is, as the controller--
suppose I'm the controller,
I have the algorithm.
And my computer starts
beeping and gets all excited.
I have to respond
quickly to this,
because that
opportunity will pass.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And getting back
to algorithms and
anticipation, what's
sort of neat about
algorithms is that you
can try to predict that this
will happen rather than waiting
until it happens to react.
And if you can do
that early enough,
you might actually
instruct a bus
that is departing the terminal
to short term later on.
And if you do that, then
you can set the head sign
on the bus to the short version.
And people who are
boarding it are
going to know that
it's going to be
short term so you won't
have to coordinate
with the bus next to it.
You don't have to have
a bunch, in other words.
So you can then
minimize the problem
to finding a long gap
here and predicting
when that gap will meet the next
bus that's being dispatched.
You need algorithms for that.
It's very difficult to do it.
AUDIENCE: What do you
tell the passengers?
Do you tell the passengers,
listen, guys, this bus
might get short termed,
just so you know.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: No.
You change the head sign.
And you say this bus is running
to Central Square instead
of Harvard.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
you know this is going
to happen during commute hours?
Like the red line--
I mean, I suppose for trains,
the red line is so long.
But if you know your [?OE?] are
mainly in the downtown area,
wouldn't you know beforehand
that you want to just have
higher frequency
on this one branch?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
That would
be a service planning,
short terming strategy, not
a real-time control strategy.
So we make the distinction.
Both are short terming,
but this is something
that you decide in real time
to bring the service that you
are delivering more close
to what you plan to deliver.
Which is different from strategy
in service planning, where
you identify when we talked
about rider or quarter
strategies.
There might be a core of your
route that has higher demand
and you have short terms to have
frequency higher at that point.
Very different
reasons and horizons
for planning and
all sorts of things.
OK, use of reserve vehicles,
this happens more with rail
than bus.
You could have it
with bus, too, though.
I know that in South
America they do it with bus.
So you have some buses
stationed somewhere
in the city near key routes.
And they're just waiting
there for an opportunity.
[LAUGHTER]
[CHATTER]
Right.
So then someone in a control
center sees a long gap
and they call that bus and say,
there's a big, long gap there.
Rush.
Go into that corridor and
start operating Route X. So
they can inject a vehicle.
And you can do that with rail,
too, if you have pocket tracks.
So you might have pocket tracks
somewhere and sort of insert
a train.
Ari knows something about that.
OK, so mostly, if
you do holding,
holding's the best strategy
for keeping service on track.
You don't usually want to do
the more aggressive strategies
because they hurt
passengers and they require
much more coordination effort.
But if you have a
major disruption,
sometimes you need them.
Holding by itself won't cut it.
Holding can be done in a
bunch of different ways.
You can hold to
schedule adherence.
We've spoken about that.
For headway, we've
kind of brushed it off
and said headway adherence.
Well, there's actually a
lot of ways you can do that.
So one of them is to
look at the schedule
and realize that the time
between scheduled trips
is five minutes.
So now instead of
actually trying
to stick to the
actual times, you
want to stick to a separation of
five minutes between vehicles,
because that's the time
that was scheduled.
So that would be scheduled
headway adherence.
The next-- and these are
in order of sophistication.
So the next one is
threshold headway adherence.
So if you think
about it, there's
no reason why the scheduled
difference between departure
times is the best threshold
that you should use for holding.
There might be one that is a
minute less or a minute higher
that results in
better performance.
Why not?
What physical reason is
there for the scheduled
time being the best one.
There isn't any.
So if you optimize
the threshold,
you can get better performance.
And usually the optimal
threshold is below,
it's shorter than the schedule.
So you hold less often.
The problem with
headway adherence
is that you hold too
much, essentially.
So then there's
headway regularity.
Don't worry about
the schedule at all,
or about any
predetermined headway.
You have a separation
between vehicles.
And I know that if
I have vehicles,
I want my vehicles
spaced this way.
But instead, I have
this situation.
So I want this vehicle
to hold until it is here.
Or rather, what
will really happen
is this vehicle will stay there.
You will ask it to stay there.
And you want this
vehicle to move on
and this vehicle to move
on to these positions.
And now they're
even, and then you
let that vehicle
go at that point.
So that's even headway holding.
AUDIENCE: That seems
pretty easy to implement.
How often is it--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Now it is.
It used to be very hard.
So how would you implement
targeted headway holding
without technology?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No, but how would you?
You can't do it.
AUDIENCE: You need a
supervisor [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
You need a supervisor.
So in London there
was actually a time
when you didn't
need a supervisor
because you had the driver
getting off the bus,
and hitting a button on a
post, and it starts a timer,
and then the driver leaves.
The next bus comes along
and it sees the time.
So it knows, like, ah, OK,
this is when I have to leave.
So you can do that, even
without wireless communication.
Even in headway
you can't do that.
You need communication.
Somebody needs to know
the vehicle before,
the vehicle after, that
means they communicated.
So it's much more of a
recent strategy in terms of--
AUDIENCE: Oh, so
in this strategy
you're not necessarily trying
to maintain a certain headway.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No certain headway.
It's often when it
emerges from the system.
AUDIENCE: OK.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Yep.
And that's actually-- if
we want to split hairs,
there's different kinds of
ways of doing unit headway.
And let's not get into it.
Then the most sophisticated
class is optimization.
And there's something called
rolling horizon optimization.
So what happens there is
that you use a simulation
model, essentially, to
predict how the system would
evolve if you're holding time
for a certain configuration.
And you can test a bunch of
different headway holding
configurations and
pick the one that's
best at a given time
based on those forecasts.
In other words, pick the holding
time that maximizes performance
across forecasts.
And so what's neat about this is
that they can trade off waiting
time and in-vehicle time.
When you hold, the people inside
the vehicle are waiting more.
The winners of this strategy are
people who would miss that bus
and have to wait for
the following bus that
has a long headway ahead of it.
So by evening out
the headways, you
make everybody wait
about the same.
And that minimizes average
waiting time and average
crowding, et cetera.
So optimization strategy
can predict or keep
track of how many people
are inside vehicles.
And it can know, well, I
know this is the penalty.
I know this is the benefit.
Let's trade these off and let's
hold the optimal amount of time
such that the total
time is minimized.
And you can multiply
by factors that
take into account this utility
of waiting being higher
than the disutility of
being inside the vehicle.
So what that does is it
reduces excessive holding.
So if you know that you
have a full vehicle,
you don't hold it, even if it's
very close to the next one.
Why would you hold
a vehicle that
is full, even if it's this
one right here bunched
to the next one.
You don't.
You don't want to hold it.
What if the vehicle isn't
full, but it will be full
five stops ahead, because demand
is very high for some reason.
And you know that.
Then optimization algorithm
will see that because it's
predicting for next hour.
So it'll be able to
pick a strategy that
improves performance.
One challenge is drivers.
If you hold too
much, then drivers
might be 20 minutes
late for their shift,
for their meal break.
What do you do about that?
That's still a challenge.
And that's a
challenge throughout.
But there is opportunity
with optimization algorithms
to insert constraints that
take those into account so
that your holding
policy is something
that you can implement.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
[INAUDIBLE] would be
to [INAUDIBLE] the algorithm.
If it's taking 45
minutes to come up
with this great solution,
then [INAUDIBLE]..
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: So
this problem is [INAUDIBLE]..
And if you crunched
all the possibilities,
you would never finish.
So you need a very
good algorithm
to find something fast.
Yeah.
So there's two different
ways of doing rolling horizon
optimization.
One way is to have constant
running times in demands
within the prediction horizon.
So imagine this blue
window being your--
this is the time right
now, and you're predicting
over the next, say, hour.
And that's the blue window.
What is actually happening is
that your running times are
going up slowly and gradually.
Your demand is going
up slowly, gradually
because you're in the PND.
If you are using
static input, you
have to say what the running
time is for the whole horizon.
So what you might do is break
up the day into periods.
And if you start at this
time, anytime before this,
you set some average.
And then once you
cross that threshold,
you set a different average.
But then you miss out
on some information.
So I worked on a
model that actually
takes some dynamic
inputs, too, to consider
these transitions, essentially.
And the way it works is you
have these dynamic functions
of running times and demand.
You can see the
current system state.
You send that to a model.
The model passes on those
inputs and some holding time
configuration to a performance
model, which essentially
forecasts what the
system would do,
how the vehicle would move,
where passengers would board,
all those things.
And then that gets sent to
a cost model, which says,
how much are people waiting?
How much are people in vehicles?
Let's add those up and figure
out what the average is.
And then that gets sent back
to the optimization model,
and the optimization
model says, what
if we, instead of doing
that, let's turn this knob
and increase that holding
time and decrease this one,
go again.
So it can do that on
a loop, essentially,
until it finds optimal times.
The objective function is the
average time in the system.
So Wv is like extra
time in the vehicle.
So it's the time
that a person spends
at a stop in the vehicle, not
moving because the vehicle is
being held.
So you're adding
time to that person.
And then Ws is waiting
time at the stop.
And we can multiply
by some factor
because we know that waiting
time is more onerous.
There's a bunch of constraints.
I'll skip the differences
between static and dynamic.
Essentially it's
that running time
so demand can be
functions of time now.
Here's what happens.
So here we test four
different strategies.
The first one here, TH,
is threshold holding.
EH is even headway holding.
OS is optimization
of static inputs,
and OD is optimization
with dynamic inputs.
And then we tested--
if we look at the
bottom two sets of four,
these are cases where both of
the men and the running times
are dynamic.
So they're both transient.
And we tested a
case of low crowding
and a case of high crowding.
So what we see is that in
all cases of low crowding--
by the way, the bottom 2/3 sets
of runs are cases where maybe
running times are dynamic but
demand isn't, or demand is
dynamic and running
times aren't.
So if you look at all the
cases of low crowding,
the white ones here, there's
very little difference
in performance.
So it means that
you don't really
need the most
sophisticated strategy.
And the benefit of a very
sophisticated optimization
strategy with dynamic
inputs is not really
going to bring you
a lot of benefit.
If you look at the high
crowding case, what you see
is that there is a pretty
significant benefit
of even headway holding over
even optimized threshold
holding.
But moving to the
model with optimization
doesn't do much
for you if there's
a lot of sort of dynamics
and system potentially.
So part of that is because the
static inputs high information
about when those
vehicles will fill up.
And when you insert that
information into the system,
then the optimizer can
see more of what happens
and can improve performance.
Here to the left is lower
cost and therefore better.
Yeah, there's more
to parse here,
but we're running
out of time, so I'm
going to skip a few slides.
So you have control problems,
routine disturbances
where you lose speed
adjustments and holding lightly.
Then there's
short-term disruptions
that might last between
five and 30 minutes.
And there you can
apply the strategies
that we've discussed.
And then there's very long,
much longer interruptions
in service for which you
need to do something major,
like bringing out bus service
to replace train service.
And so only holding,
short terming,
expressing, deadheading,
they're not going to cut it.
You have a much bigger
problem to deal with.
Here's a situation
in a rail operation
where there's a signal
failure, or perhaps there's
a suicide attempt, and there's
a person on the tracks.
And you have this train that's
standing there and can't move.
So the first thing
you should do is
hold the trains
downstream, immediately
downstream of the blockage.
If you don't do that, they
will run around and queue up
on the other end.
And the people
entering these stations
are going to wait a long time.
and those stations
are going to fill up.
The other thing you should do is
these trains that are lined up
here should be expressed
as soon as the blockage is
cleared up so that you can
move those vehicles forward.
And the vehicles at
the end of the queue
can begin normal operation.
Does that make sense?
A lot of the very
sophisticated models
are not used in practice
for a number of reasons.
Sometimes it's that the
models are simplistic.
Sometimes it's sort of a
lack of faith in models.
Often it has to do with
the data in real time
about where vehicles
are not being that good.
So actually detecting
where vehicles are
could be a major challenge.
And you need that information to
make the determination of what
the optimal strategy is.
Recently our lab did a
pilot of a real experiment
with the Green Line holding
two headways instead
of the schedule.
So right now they
use paper sheets
and they have a schedule.
And Jeff Fabian, who's
a student in the lab,
designed an app that has all the
train and driver information.
And it also calculates the
even headway departing time.
So that departure time which
would cause an even headway.
And for two weeks we had the
inspectors of the terminal
use that instead of
the paper schedule.
And what happened-- here's
a picture of the app.
So you have all the
trains for the day.
There's color coding.
So green is coming
up and you can see
all these times are different.
So 9:36, there's some extra
holding there for the train
that had been scheduled at 9:34
so that the headways are even
coming out.
And here's what happened.
The variability decreased
by about 40% in some cases,
if you look at the
coefficient of variation.
And you only look at
trains that were compliant.
What really happened
overall was a mix of things.
There was some noncompliance
with headway times,
some insistence in departing
on time to the schedule,
and then sometimes a compliance
to the [INAUDIBLE] headway
policy.
So here's the
coefficient of variation.
You know what that is.
You know that lower is better
and the Green Line is lower,
so it's better.
You can calculate the
equivalent benefit
that you would get
by adding trains
to service in terms of
decreasing waiting time.
You can increase frequency
by adding new trains.
So decrease in
variability of headways
was equivalent to
adding 1.7 trains.
Which is money.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but if I'm not
mistaken-- you can correct me
if I'm wrong.
There is a mechanism
in this algorithm
that tries to go back
gradually to the schedule.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No, I wouldn't
characterize it that way.
There are constraints to prevent
situations where there aren't
enough trains to be departed.
And there are some constraints
on how much holding
there can be, et cetera.
So yeah, there's
an intention not
to have too much of a cascading
holding throughout the day.
But it's not so much as
a programmed linear trend
towards schedule or
anything like that.
AUDIENCE: Because you're
going off schedule, does--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Slightly.
AUDIENCE: Slightly.
So would you ever
run into issues
with communicating
with the public?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: Green
Line, especially in peaks,
high frequency, not running
very reliably, anyway.
So I don't know anyone
that looks at the schedule.
Maybe very early in the
morning, but I don't know.
Maybe late at night,
but I don't know.
AUDIENCE: I've totally
used Green Line's schedule
late at night.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Late at night.
Yeah, late at night, I
think it would happen.
But I don't think that during
the day it would happen.
And what happened with
this late at night
is that the schedule
is reliable enough
that the even headway times are
the scheduled times, anyway.
So there's no issue with that.
AUDIENCE: So would there be an
issue in terms of applying this
to a more robust system?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: We
learned a lot from this pilot.
And I think whoever implements
the next rail system will
have to rejudge his thesis.
Because there's so much that
we learned, about compliance,
about issues with data.
I recommend reading it.
Eli.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
how it's determining
the headway that it should be?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's even headway.
AUDIENCE: It's just
maintaining event.
It's not like optimizing.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
No optimization.
It's a very simple
even headway strategy.
Prediction of the time
it takes this train
to reach the next
one, prediction
of the time it takes
the trailing train
to arrive at the
terminal, and then
using those to calculate
the headways, essentially.
And then determining
the holding time
to keep that train
the middle and then
adding some constraints to
prevent excessive holding.
Also to prevent-- if
there was a long gap,
you might want to not hold
the second one too much.
Send those together.
Here's something interesting.
Here's a space-time graph.
Time horizontal.
Green here shows compliance
and red shows non-compliance.
So the first thing
we see is that when
there's a lot of green, those
lines are nicely evenly spaced.
So that's good.
That's the lower
coefficient to variation.
When you see red, you see
some bunching later on.
That doesn't happen immediately.
And it's slight.
Notice how slight the
deviations can be.
But you see the effects
of the dwell time effect
and the crunching happening.
The other thing that happens
is that they have someone
controlling at reservoir.
So they have someone stationed
there holding trains,
keeping them evenly
spaced, more or less.
And which trains are being held?
The ones that are
not as green, right?
So you've sent a train that
might be full of people.
And you've decided
that you somehow
need it to depart a
little bit earlier
than the algorithm said.
And then you wait till you fold
to them and hold two minutes.
You could have avoided that
by having left a little later
from the terminal.
AUDIENCE: They're
never hold at Fenway?
Fenway seems to--
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: No.
No, just long hold times.
So that's the end.
Sorry for being a
few minutes late.
If you have questions on
holding or real-time control,
let me know.
Next lecture is on fare policy.